this model is showing how a human spine
forms in an embryo
this process for creating body segments
like vertebrae is known as sometogenesis
but while it has been studied in animals
like frogs or mice it remains difficult
to observe in humans but now this new
model is offering scientists a glimpse
of this crucial developmental step
studying the development of human
embryos is very difficult both
technically and ethically with strict
rules governing the use of embryos in
research
this new model which the researchers
call an axioloid aims to get around
these problems by creating a surrogate
for an embryo in a dish using human
pluripotent stem cells
to build the axioloid the researchers
exposed stem cells to chemical signals
which triggered them to differentiate
into various embryonic structures one by
one they introduced different signals
before embedding the cells into a
scaffold called a metrogel a carefully
constructed Matrix of proteins like
laminin and collagen by mimicking the
factors which influence the
transformation of stem cells into
embryonic cells the team can model what
happens in real life embryo development
what starts as Blobs of cells begins to
grow and differentiate into structures
forming segments and symmetry in a
coordinated way in essence this is the
process of somatogenesis where lumps of
tissue start to form in pairs along the
length of an embryo These Lumps could
then go on to form the spine as well as
lots of other tissues which make up body
parts like muscle cartilage and tendons
modeling this process could give
scientists a new platform to study human
development and disease
for example it has been suggested that
disorders like scoliosis might be linked
to problems during somatogenesis and the
researchers were able to model this in
laraxioloid disrupting somedogenesis to
demonstrate features of various
congenital diseases of the human spine
the authors say their approach shows
that complex developmental processes can
be broken down into their fundamental
building blocks and their axioloids give
them a platform to better understand and
even manipulate these developmental
events in minute detail